[inaudible]
I want to welcome all of you all to
Google and to the youtube space. Um,
I can't imagine that anybody
doesn't know who these people are.
We got Chris Webber, Lisa,
Leslie, Nate Robinson,
[inaudible]
4 times Olympian, five times, all
star, three times, slam dunk champion.
The list of accomplishments
goes on and on. Next. Nate,
the only one's ever actually done that.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
um, but we're not talking about a number
of things today. I'm excited to be here.
I'm Nelson voice by the way.
I work at here at Google and I'm thrilled
to have the best seat in the House
with these lovely folks up here today.
Um, so everybody knows, I think that, uh,
uncle drew in theaters
nationwide on Friday,
of which all of these folks are
stars. Uh, it's going to be exciting.
I saw the movie last night. It
was incredible, um, in very,
very funny and all of your digit thing.
I will tell you that for sure. Um,
just to give you all a little bit of
the premise of the movie. Um, there's a,
a gentleman who under
unfortunate circumstances is
unable to feel his team at
the Rucker. So for those of
you who don't know Rutgers,
a playground tournament up in Harlem,
happens every year. It's incredible.
A number of historic players
have come out of that. Uh,
but there's one player in particular
played by Kyrie Irving who has the
opportunity to go ahead and field a team,
uh,
from the past,
if you will,
to come back and play the
Rucker once again in hopes
of winning the championship.
And that's when all these
folks come into play. Um,
it's based on the character of Uncle Joe.
You all,
some of you may know based on a Pepsi,
uh,
created digital episodic,
that was very popular and ultimately
became a movie, uh, with lion's gate,
our friends at lion's gate.
So to that end, uh, you know,
this question is for everyone.
How did this come together? Right?
How did it go from kind
of an episodic to a movie?
And did your agents reach out to you
or did you guys actually audition? Uh,
how did it work? Well,
Lisa definitely audition.
I'm gonna let her tell y'all stories.
It's awesome.
Her story is pretty cool tomorrow, but,
uh, I just booked hiree until you told me.
Yes. So every, every game that
we had, I played against them.
We, you know, he's at the Fredo
mine and I'm like, [inaudible],
so can I be down bugging them every
time you check it in the game, Bro,
I'm serious. We're up. So, uh, you know,
then he hit me on Twitter. It was like,
were you serious about, you know, being
in a commercial? And I was like, yeah,
of course. Of course. And, uh, and
that's, that's how, that's how I'm here.
The origins for next. Okay.
Lisa, what about you? I got it.
My agent called and that they are
doing,
they were shooting for uncle drew and
there was a part for Betty Lou who's
played the wife, a preacher and
Chris Webber place preacher.
And he hadn't had the part
that time at that time,
but I was going to be the wife.
And Betty Lou obviously has to get
buckets at some point. So, you know,
I wasn't concerned about
that, but I'm like, okay, so
tell me more about Betty Lou.
Betty Lou has to be in her seventies
and I'm like, okay, got it.
So I get off the phone with my agent and
I go out of my closet and I go shopping
a little bit and I came up and I was like,
Babe,
I was telling my husband who
I called Babe. I said, Dave,
been harder for me to get this part.
I'm going to have to go
in dressed as Betty Lou.
Like they have to believe I can
do this. So I went in full, full.
I was Betty Lou when I walked into,
when I got off the elevator,
I was bent over hunched.
Hey Baby. Hey y'all don't,
I came in and talking to everybody.
Oh yeah, Betty Lewis here.
And can you just get the producer?
No one showed up because they said
they needed me to come full, please.
You better move.
So I just walked in being Betty Lou.
Oh,
everything with my bible and a Joe.
My agent called and said, I got the
park fiery character in the movie.
And what about to print? And she didn't
tell you about her thought how stock is
going to stop short.
Exactly.
Uh,
I got a call and I think that the part
was already cast it and I knew that they
were part of it.
And of course I'm big fan of native,
don't know Nate and Lisa is probably the
out of all the athletes private acting
along this and modeling all
this stuff she did. And so, uh,
I've been in the church my whole life.
He's just going to ask
you about that because
my father is like a deacon in the church.
My mom was a choir director,
someone who kids would get whooped,
visiting the church to come back and
have to sit up there and all that stuff.
And so it was, uh, you know,
it wasn't a better role for me than to
be a basketball player, which, you know,
I played basketball and then to emulate
some of the passages I knew growing up.
So I tried to take them along
with some great movies. You know,
you know all the other guys that have
done it and hopefully, uh, it's, it's,
you know, when you say it a
good movie, I'm thinking of
the audience. They're like,
yeah, right. Because that's,
I think we all knew it had the
potential to be Super Corny, super bad,
terrible.
And uh,
know the answer to that get,
what did I get to keep my brand reel?
The script was funny
when I read the script,
I was laughing out loud and I was like,
you know what, this is going to be funny.
So in the movie or at night, it was good
that it came up like that. Now, I mean,
I had the benefit of being
at the premiere and you,
you brought a little extra something
to it. I will tell you that, oh,
I'm not going to give it away,
but there's a scene in the church
that you all will remember free.
Amen.
So a little bit more about the movie,
right? I mean, I think the kind of
underlying foundation about what's
there is the pure love for basketball.
Um, can you share with the, with the
audience and the folks here today,
the moment that you fell
in love with the game?
Well, you know, I didn't fall
in love with the game initially.
I was not as sporty girl.
I was really more into like I
don't want to get hurt. My cousins,
I had two amazing, I have amazing
girl cousins who were like tough.
I mean they're running,
they're kicking butt and they're playing
football with the boys and I was on the
side like, do you guys need water?
Like how is this not really,
really know this is true story.
I mean I was the cry baby of the family.
Like I'm not, I wasn't really tough.
But basketball for me really found me.
I think it was more my destiny because
I started playing in the seventh grade
and I only played basketball because there
was a girl who was in the ninth grade
who was so popular. I'm like,
why does everybody know her?
And her name was Shay and she was on the
basketball team and at that I want to
be popular. Hmm. So I'm
going to play basketball,
but I had one rule. If
I fall down, I'm done.
Thank God I did not fall down. Our team
went seven and Oh, I won my first trophy.
Smaller than this cup. No lie. And that
show you have a say you get a trophy.
I fell in love with, I got the
trophy, the trophy to gold medal.
I mean the fact that you,
that was it.
And I really fell in love it and I put
in so much work and I realized that it
would open up doors.
I could get scholarship to college.
My mom was not going to be able to
afford a division one school. Um,
and so then it started to make sense
having good grades and playing basketball.
I was really in education. Very nerdy. I
know. Then look like it. No, just good.
I was really into school.
I really loved school,
but basketball just opened so many doors
that I had to stick with it. Beautiful.
Beautiful. And that is your
championship writing, is it not?
What's this one is not.
Okay.
This one is my top 20 w NBA players.
Of all time.
[inaudible]
on top of all that to the
other ones are too healthy.
Nate, what about you? When did you
fall in love with the money from me?
I was brainwashed at a young
age man watching Michael Jordan.
I mean that's as a kid, you know, that's
all you saw on TV for the most part.
Uh, you know, it was watching guys
like that that helped me, you know,
believe that, you know, there is a way
for me, a little guy from Seattle to,
you know, make it to the league and I was
just, I'm, I'm, I'm a different animal.
I would just hungry as a young
kid, 10 years old. I just,
I just knew what I wanted to do.
Yeah.
Since that day and after that
I just never looked back. Yeah.
You were still hungry, man. Yes. As
you want a mix. I'm a diehard fans.
We can use it. And what about you, Chris?
And he was killing when he was
on the Knicks to, first of all,
it made be a real humble too, because
he could gone to a pro in football.
That's why I want to stand up.
Cause
I think basketball shows you,
it's not about your size,
but it's about your heart.
You look at AI as small athlete.
One of the nicest killers I've ever
known in the game. And these guys,
one of the best athletes
the League has ever seen.
I mean he's won three
dunk contest or great, uh,
DB and could have gone to the league.
So he,
he definitely was a different animal
for me. I wanted to play football,
I wanted to, that's what I want
it to be a football player.
And I fell in love playing
sports in the street. You know,
like we had a neighborhood that had
a bunch of kids. So, uh, you know,
in the summertime it was on two square
running basis, like playing games.
And so I just fell in love with sports.
I just fell in love with friends
and competition, that camaraderie.
And I've been this height since ninth
grade. So yeah, my body told me like,
you do this, don't go over
there and football, are they
going to break away? So,
you know, it came natural, but I
always want it to be an athlete.
That's awesome. I didn't,
didn't seem try out for Seattle.
I tried out for to see how yeah,
they gave me a little,
I wouldn't call it a semi semi.
Yeah, it was pretty cool. You know,
I got to work out in
front of Pete Carroll,
the owners and a Russell Wilson was there.
That was pretty cool.
He gave me a football, signed the football
for me. So yeah, I'm more of a, um,
I'm more of a fan a lot of the time. Like
I get, I get geeked out scene, you know,
different athletes. Pretty cool. Good
stuff. Speaking of players, right,
as you guys were,
as the movie came together,
were there any other NBA
or w NBA players that, uh,
you know,
tried to maybe join the cast that didn't
work out or what would you have liked
to have seen in the movie?
Uh,
you mean as in take our spots?
No, not in taking your spots. No, there,
there weren't any other players.
We played against other players,
but there weren't a,
other than,
I think Gordon was the only other NBA
player. Right? Yeah, yeah. That was it.
So assuming there's a sequel
and I hope there would be one,
who would you want to see join
you all in the movie? Well,
Kevin Duran was at the premier.
Yeah.
And I told them after the move,
because before I was like,
I know what you're thinking. I was like,
it's not going to be corn. He trusts me.
He was like, all right. And then after
he was like, Oh man, I love it. I'm in,
I'm in part two. I was like, I don't tell
me bye. I'll be your agent. I want to go.
Who are you? But, uh, you know, it would
be fun to have Kevin Duran. I mean,
to dress up, you know, we're all 70 years
old plus in this movie. So, you know,
to dress up and have some older guys,
it, it, it'll be fun. Definitely.
But I think our crew, the fact
that we were all athletes,
the fact that, you know,
we're used to being vulnerable,
we used to working hard.
We used to ask him for help,
um, that, that really made
it a collaborative effort.
The fact we didn't want
to let each other down.
I didn't want to let Betty Lou down
and boots didn't want to let us down.
And so it was uh,
it was really unique.
They say when you retired you missed
the locker room and not the games.
And I think that's true.
And I got the locker room with these guys
and know it was, I feel sorry for our
director Charles Stone, cause I'm sure
it was like a professor teaching a
uh,
a kindergarten class cause we were
having fun every second, every second.
All right,
let's hurry up.
Take the take an after that he would pull
out a backpack with music and all the
extras, it'd be dancing. He's like, oh
no. Slow down. It's not. But we have fun.
Definitely set the whole,
the time.
So you mentioned two things. I want
to talk about a little bit more. Uh,
so the makeup, oh man. Talk a
little bit about that. Cause I mean,
it was full on transformation
for all of them. I kind of, uh,
for the first time I called
my mom, I'm like, mom,
I'm sorry for mega funny you for
Phnom Maaco for hours. It sucked.
Like literally is sitting there hours
doing the makeup. I'm like, man,
so this is what takes women's soul.
Tell my girl like I feel you.
So, uh, it was, it was tough. A little
difficult for hours for my makeup,
cause he know he had to cover all the
tattoos and stuff for me. But it was,
it was,
it was still fun.
Once I got the four hours out of the way
and [inaudible] care of there, I'm like,
yeah, when, when do we start?
Yeah. Yeah. So yeah, it was
long for me. Same experience.
Yeah.
And women were a little bit
more accustomed to being
in a chair and not quite
two and a half to three hours.
So to get ready to be Betty Lou
and have the prosthetics put on.
I tried to think of it as
being in the spa, you know,
Tom down
Sunday.
And I would put my headsets on the
wireless ones and take it behind my neck.
And then I watched insecure and game
of Thrones. So this was last August.
So you know, I have to
finish up the season. Right.
So I just watch that every day until
I had to have my eyes shut. And then,
you know, I was good. The heart,
I think the hardest part is probably
taken it off cause I'm like yeah cause we
had to wear wigs. Well yeah we all have
wigs also. You know, I'm like listen,
edges are really important. I mean
I'm like listen, cause they, you know,
they want to put blue.
I'm like, okay listen,
this is a movie but I need you to just
pin this down and pin this down and Betty
Lou will be fine. Uh, so,
but the takeoff is a little strenuous
because they have to basically exfoliate
your face. Oh Wow. Yeah. And that's
scrubbing it. And I'm like, listen,
we need to look good.
Chris had some little bit of rehash.
Actually I think you had
the biggest struggle.
I felt like I was getting burned with
acid base is like I'm trying to me like
I'm burning and it really hurts
and my neck is coming off.
But it was three hours and uh,
weren't used to the makeup chair and
still that switch him to my face cream
actually. And this was an every day.
Some beauty lessons every day. Yeah.
Like you guys have to moisturize boys,
you need to moisturize.
I didn't even know what does that mean?
Where like when you leave here you
need to the cream on and I come back,
you know, fresh face because
I've got a book and they're like,
you don't have any irritation. I'm like,
no guys, you'd have to moisturize it.
So important for your life.
Rhodan and fields guys look me up.
Green juice, word makeups
coaches right now. Healthy
makeup coats.
We had a green juice every morning.
We do manage Kale, blueberry,
Lisa Cobb was, you know,
and thanks for keeping.
I'm the mom.
And you also mentioned the fund that
you all had on set and the dancing, um,
I'm not going to give
the whole thing away,
but there is a dance battle in this movie
and I just wanted to kind of get the
real, get the real school. So,
so who's got the most skills?
Nae [inaudible] me,
I just couldn't wait to
start the deadline. May,
can we hurry this up like this is, this
is my thing right here. Like the music,
the fun it was,
it was for,
who surprised me most was Reggie Miller
because he couldn't dance a lick and he
would, he got out, he got out there,
really show what he can do it. Reggie,
we were currently practicing
at our lunchtime there.
But the funny thing here,
the funny thing is during lunch
we are literally in our makeup,
but we can't take our,
our makeup off.
So we're literally having conversations
like this. But it was like funny. I was,
I was telling us, he was like, Bro, this
is funny. You got to tell an MBA story.
I mean,
I remember when I used to dunk on shack
and I'm looking at him when you look
like a real pretty sure Chris around
you're looking at, you know, it was,
it was pretty cool. Just the whole
dancing and getting Reggie, you know,
ready to dance with zero money. He was
nervous the whole time. My gorgeous.
Just enjoy yourself. I said just
you're in a mess. You're good.
Nobody even knows to do your days.
But he did a great job.
So you put them through a clinic?
Yeah.
How do you get them right ready
to go to weddings and stuff.
He was socially awkward. Like you
don't want it here. If I hit you with a
back strain.
Has Anybody at a party,
what have you,
Nate dance class 101 too funny.
Um,
in terms of anxiety and all of you
have done some level of acting, right?
First pro game or first day on the set.
Which one was more nerve wracking
first program? Yeah, for sure. For me.
Yeah.
First pro game for sure.
At least you get a second take and you
can mess up your check in the Cayman
Lodge and why your first game you, you're
done, you're gonna get embarrassed,
period. That's what is
going to be. So yeah,
I'd much rather do that
then in the first game.
I hear that, I hear that. So we'll,
we'll pivot away from the movie for a
second and talk a little bit more about
kind of a career and
life stuff, right. Um,
what was the most challenging time in
your career and how did you overcome it?
Oh Wow.
And use this
dag deep. Huh? Most challenging
time? Probably I would, my
career was when I was at USC,
um, as a college student.
And I would say it was challenging because
I went to USC and it's a school that
is a private school that students are
known to be a little bit wealthier than
the average.
And so I remember there being times where
I didn't have like a lot of money as a
student athlete and you know, like you'll
have five bucks and you're like, okay,
I'm an order a Burrito, cut it in half.
And he this half at this point and he,
this happened the other time.
There were times where I remember that,
but I also remember thinking like, this
is not the way it's always going to be.
Right. But I really, I wouldn't
say I enjoy my struggle,
but I understood when I was in moments
when I didn't have that, you know,
it was up to me to figure out
ways and to find a way to make it,
and it wasn't my mom's job. You
know, once you get to college,
it's like you gotta you
gotta figure it out.
You've got to figure out
how you're going to make it,
how you going to be successful.
And that's why lean so much
on my education and getting
my master's in business
and just really wanting to make sure that,
you know,
I would never be in that situation
again financially. Oh Wow.
I'm so blessed and
thankful. I, I love the,
I just feel like we have so
many opportunities and you
have to keep taking them
in now with social media and just so
much information at our fingertips is
there's no reason why people should not
be doing what they love to do their job.
They lift. I just haven't had five
jobs. I overdo it because of what,
probably my struggle. But, um, you know,
that's the compensation I think I make
sure Nate, Chris, anything to
contribute to that challenging time?
I would say mine, it didn't come until
I got to the league, to the NBA really.
Cause you know, everything's been hard
for me. So being a little guy, sure.
You know, so, but the hardest one
thing when I got to the NBA was like,
they wanted me to be
somebody that I wasn't.
And now for me that was the hardest
thing because I was just like, Yo,
I just thought as a kid I just want to
play basketball, you know? So, you know,
they were big on, you know, attitude
and the way you add behavior.
And it was just hard for me. I'm like,
Bro, I just want to hope. I just,
I'm happy to be here.
You know, every game.
It was like different superstar
Vince Carter today. All words, right?
Like this is crazy. So I was just enjoying
the moment. I was enjoying the moment.
So my biggest struggle was like
every, every day. It was like,
all right and you got to chill,
like blah, blah, blah. I'm like,
you guys are so worried about
everything other than basketball.
And I didn't understand
that. So that was, for me,
that was the hardest thing
dealing with, you know, being a,
a starter and a player that you play
all the time your whole life and come to
the league and you're just coming off
the bench. Some games you don't play.
That was hard. That was really hard
for me. But I enjoyed the ride.
I enjoyed the ups and downs
and roller coaster was fun.
It was challenging and I had the
best seat in the house every night.
That's all I had to switch. How I thought
the process of not playing. I'm like,
you know what? I'm going to just embrace
this. You know? I'm going to just embrace,
you know, me not playing and then I'm
gonna just get on everybody's nerves,
ass jerseys. I need
shack, I need your jersey.
I was going to ask every different person
for their stuff to keep me, to keep me,
you know, where I needed
to be. So absolutely right.
Chris, what about you man?
Like you just said,
it's been a little coasters and I
think that for me it was my rookie year
because I was having
success,
but at home,
people in my neighborhood was going
through things that I couldn't help them
with back in the truck.
So it was a little bit of like
survivor's remorse and you know,
you have to take responsibility
for the choices that you make.
But some of my friends, uh, at that
time, they choices that, you know,
I'll never see them again
when they were killed or,
or whether they're in jail for the rest
of their life. And so, yeah, here it is.
You know, you're reaching the dream and
you're making it and you're loving it.
And, uh, you know, when
you're younger, sensitive,
you should be sensitive all the time,
but you're young and you're wondering
why you and why not them, you know?
And I just remember the whole season.
I don't think I enjoyed it as much
because I was living at home and my mind
wanting to bring them with me and will,
and then to see all of this
stuff and things I've never seen.
It's the most exciting time in the world.
And you have people you can't see it and
don't realize, listen, you, you know, you,
you can do whatever you
want. You know, it's,
I just met somebody out
here and it's doing great.
And they didn't even finish second grade.
They just had a hard work at the look.
You can do it, you know,
more stories and inspiration.
I wanted to take that to
them and let them see it.
But it was really hard at that time to,
to find that balance.
You want to save the world and all your
friends at one time and it takes a while
to sell. For me, that was tough.
Having success reaching a dream and
in the kids that I dreamed with. Hmm.
You know we veered off at a point
of a dream and it was like, Dang,
I wish you could bring me with, so
that was tough. There was talking.
I hate it and I can relate
to that area very well.
Um Oh we'll say
man, I've got like four or five
questions. I wish I could ask you,
but we're gonna make sure that we spend
enough time letting some of the folks in
the audience asks you some questions.
But before we go there,
we're going to do a little speed round.
Oh it's, you guys want to play games?
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I told him
cause all of you went in this one.
So this is, this is going to be a,
it's not fair cause she
always wins the games we play
seriously. But this is a, this or that.
Throw out two things and you just go,
don't think about it too much.
Just choose one or the other.
What is our answer?
The answer is one or one or the other.
You'll see.
[inaudible]
we're going to start with Nate and we're
going to go to Chris and we don't keep
going back around. All
right. Dog or cat? Dog. Oh,
Mac or PC?
Mac.
Text or call. Call. But I'm lying.
[inaudible]
live or on demand. Oh Man. Uh,
I'm gonna say live. Alright. Go to
the store or order online. Got It.
Okay.
Online. Okay. Online for sure.
Bacon or butter.
Oh,
butter dunk or three pointer up.
Duh.
Question player or coach
player.
Hot to cold.
Hot vacation or staycation?
I'm a home body. Staycation.
Lebron or harden?
Uh, Brian. Beyonce or Rihanna?
Beyonce.
Ariana.
Oh No, I'm sorry. I'll wait both too.
Oh, awake or asleep? No,
man is early in the morning right now.
I know.
I'll wake biggie or Tupac.
Come on.
California law,
Chris. And on Solo or two week. Oh yeah.
So it got frozen empire strikes back
back in the day. I got to go higher.
So that is a lot of Solo Godfather.
Scarface.
Ooh. Uh, I'm gonna say
Scarface for me. Uh,
I grew up on that. Pac
man or miss man, Ms. Peck,
she was a sneakers.
Sneakers all day long.
Sneakers in this for all three
of y'all from Google or bing
[inaudible]
let's open it up to the audience.
We've got a microphone over here.
Hair.
Oh, y'all can't be shy. Thank
you. Come on now we up here.
I've got more questions I can ask.
I don't want to call it. Yeah,
that. Thanks so much for coming. This
is pretty much like a dream come true.
The question for all of you, who was
your favorite person to play again?
It's been why play against?
Yeah.
Oh, to play with. I mean either way
to play a gifts for me,
our have to shea,
it was Michael Jordan one time we
would play him in the playoffs.
You have 54 points, maybe something
like that. And I looked at Jawan,
my teammates and in front of Jordan
and we will work out when I was like,
oh, he sold his soul to the devil. He's
not supposed to be making these shots.
I know.
Trying to get them off and
I really thought like he
sold like he may stuff, man,
they do not.
It's not humid
possibly.
So it was great trying to take him down
knowing that it probably wasn't a chance
that you were going to do it.
So I stayed a great Mike Resort.
Yeah.
I think that would say Lauren Jackson.
I enjoy playing against her cause she was,
she was really a tough player to guard
and stop and we had so many battles and
yeah, she was, she, she
was, she's the real deal.
I mean from between her three point shot
and her ability to score inside was the
most challenging to stop their
pick and roll and shopper inside.
And she could block my shot only on one
side. I had finally figured that out.
I'm like, Gosh, she getting my
shot. So I had to go left. But um,
she was the most challenging player.
I think I play it again,
uh,
from,
you probably are person cause I was a
little guy growing up watching another
little guy like change the whole league.
I don't understand like what he brought
to the game. Uh, he was okay for,
he made it okay for people to be
themselves, you know? And then for me,
I hit a game winning shot over him,
changed my life forever.
Thank you
sir. Thank you all for coming. Um,
I can think of highlights of, of many of
you, the things that you all have done,
but I'm just interested in what's
your best highlight or yourself.
Oh Wow.
I could help.
[inaudible]
I would say for me my best highlight
both say mom, my children, uh,
that maybe more so than basketball. They,
they're a part of me there, you know,
I'm trying to shape them to be the best,
you know,
people they can be growing up,
sports education wise and just living
life for the full list and what it is.
So for me it would be
my children for sure.
That was such a great answer.
I was,
I thought basketball initially
when you asked. So basketball,
just in terms of highlights, I mean
it's one thing to represent, you know,
my city and state to have played in Los
Angeles for the Los Angeles sparks my
whole career,
but to have represented our country is
definitely the highlight for me to put on
the red, white and blue. And I know
we weren't like in the service,
but it feels like you go into a war
when you play against other countries.
And to come out on top,
just a little backstory,
our USA team actually lost to,
we lost in a world championship
to Brazil and as you know Brazil,
like even in soccer, they're
very animated. They cheer.
So there was so animated
and this is the problem.
They put us on the same bus
to the game and back. Right.
So on the way
that home team USA, and it was one of the
first times I got to the national team.
So I was one of the younger
players at that time.
They had made a bet with their
coach that if they beat team USA,
which is a really big deal, that
they could shave his head. Yeah.
So they shaved his head on the
bus while we rode back with him.
So that level of disrespect I've out,
we will never lose, not always to
Brazil, but we had never, you know,
cause we ended up with a bronze metal for
the world championship, which is like,
I don't even know where that metal,
if I accepted
does that or not
bratty. But the highlight then is
to go on and win four gold medals.
I have also have to world to gold
world championship medals in,
nobody ever talks about
but to go on and win,
go for the rest of my career wearing
red white blue is a highlight for me
though USA.
Oh it was awful. The clippers
out his hand, thrown it off.
Um, wow. Uh,
I'd have to start with baby playing in
college and playing with the group of
guys in the Fab five or that time.
And um,
the reason why you don't need talks about
his mentality and if you get to know
Nate, you know, he's still
that 10 year old man.
He's still a beast when it comes
to sports in this mentality.
But to be at that age,
I think all you guys understand,
or maybe you're in that space now,
to be free mentally,
to know that the world's against you and
Tim embrace it and to take it on and,
but not be bitter enough
where you've experienced thing
and it, and it turns sad.
It's more so like an embracing of taking
on the world and playing with those
guys was just so much fun because we
were on the same page. We all were dumb,
young and naive and
believe we could do it all.
And that's a great place to be when
you work hard, you know? And so, uh,
I would just say being
with those guys every day,
having them affect my life and who I was
and doing those true friendships and uh,
and then the highlights,
dunking on people too with those guys.
And I know it's a lot
of fun. Thank you, Lisa.
I'm surprised you didn't say that.
Dunk.
Yeah,
that's other people's highlights.
Yeah, that's true. Right?
Hey, thank you guys for coming and
stopping by here. Um, so fast forward,
you know, 50 years from now,
a hundred years from now, uh,
if you could have one
game that your great,
great grandchildren could
watch of yourself, which
game would you pick and why?
Oh Wow.
Wow.
Yeah.
Say I'm the,
I have not a lot of games in my whole
career where I have triple double,
but I do have one in particular
where I had 10 blocks and I,
I won defensive player year. I loved
playing, I loved playing defense. It was,
you know,
playing both ends of the court of course.
And people know about the scoring,
but I really loved defenses.
So I have one game where I
had 10 blocks and I would,
if for my son and daughter who
plays sports and plays basketball,
I would like for them to see that game
because I think that game was just so
complete, whether it was scoring
or rebounding and blocking shots,
but the defensive effort and
it was a championship. So
that was really important.
But yeah, 10 blocks,
that's pretty good. Right?
[inaudible] get that out of here.
Yeah,
that game was pretty cool.
Uh, 50 a hundred years from now when our
kids to see you said, or great grandkids,
great grandkids. I always
say, uh, I would say,
I think I had 28 points, 13
rebounds, but it was in a game.
I call a time out at the end of the game.
And I will have,
I was showing him that because I would
want them to know you're going to go
through things in your life,
even when you did your best and uh,
you won't win. Maybe you'll make
a mistake, maybe you'll lose.
But look how good of a game it was.
Look how it turned out at the end.
And hopefully they will see, wow,
that was the most dark moment.
And hopefully it would have asked the
question, what did he do after that?
You know, me. So hopefully that would
teach them to have a great game.
Do your thing, kill it. Do yourself
when, if you run into a, you know,
a big speed bump, go ahead and
cry. Get Out of your system,
get around some people that love and
support you. Forget it and keep moving.
You know, even the best guy, he's
like, Lisa talked about our 10 blocks.
I bet it's fun for her to think about
it now because when she was a player,
she's so competitive.
She didn't think about a best games then
cause she could always know I can get
11 blocks of 12 blocks.
And so hopefully through that they were
seeing our dad was a bad man. He made a,
a mistake and look at that and
then wonder how you get through it.
And hopefully that would inspire them
to never worry about the, you know,
worst moments,
even in the best times of their lives.
Yeah. I'm gonna say for me, uh,
when I played with the Knicks coach,
I had a coach named Mike
Tony who sat me down.
He didn't play me for a whole
month. I never forget this. Uh,
he sat me down for a whole month
then give me a reason or nothing.
And I'm the one new years I will,
I called my mom, I'm like, mom,
I need you to come. You know, I need
somebody there with me just to, you know,
see if real familiar face somebody that
I love and my mom's like my best friend.
So I, Florida, Atlanta, and
uh, I took her to dinner,
we went eight and I ran into the coach.
Uh,
I ran into Atlanta hawks coach and he
was like, you playing on what tomorrow?
I was like nine and been playing for like
a whole month. So it was like 14 games.
He sat me and uh,
he ended up putting me in a game the
next day and I ended up having like 41
points. We won the game, went to over
time and the whole time I kept my mom,
Sharon,
so loud. They're like over
everybody gas, right? Nate Daddy. Oh
yeah, like the whole, I'm like, yeah.
I was like, that's mom dukes. You know,
as a kid I always, you
know, you hear that,
that reassurance that mom
is there, you know what I'm
saying? For me. So, you know,
I would just,
I just played that game for her and it,
it changed my life because, you know, it
was a big story. Sports Center, you know,
a coach send you down for a month, you
know, I worked out hard before the game,
ran bleachers still did my workout.
So that would be something I would
love for my grandchildren know,
like even through, you know,
you go through adversity,
you just stay ready no matter what because
when your number's called, you know,
I could easily just not been ready and
just say whatever or even told him, no,
I don't want to go in.
I just say, you know,
I'm going to take full advantage of this.
I'm gonna see where it gives me. I said,
God, just don't let me make the
first shot because it's a wrap.
I make this first one at the, you know,
sitting down a month. So that was for me,
that'd be probably the game coming in
and helping my team and we want to,
that was a big, that was a big deal.
And all my teammates supporting me,
they showed me a lot of love. It
was pretty awesome. Thank you guys.
We're going to take one last question.
Hey, awesome. This is awesome.
So it looks like uncle drew is a movie
about old school guys teaching the young
ins. What's up, right?
So when you were young,
what's a bit of advice that you
received from somebody older,
wiser that helped you
in your success in life
with me? The first day of practice, uh,
I was drafted by golden state and
I was so excited to me Chris money.
So he's like one of the best shooters I
was seeing on New Yorker. Talk like this,
you know, I'll tell you where
I've come over here. He cannot,
cannot understand him. I'm excited
and I wanted to just be around them.
I bought a place where he lived.
I just wanted the card and he had,
I wanted to be around.
And then the craziest thing is the more
than shooting more than anything else
after practice, he brought me into
the training room and he said,
this is what I want you to do every day.
It was a hot tub and the Koto you said,
I want you to go two minutes
in the hot tub, two minutes.
Nicole took two minutes from
the hotel. I'm like, come on,
you don't need to stretch when
you're young, you can do everything.
And then I found myself doing that
every game it through all the injuries.
I found myself 15 years later doing that,
what he told me.
So he really taught me how to take
care of my body with nutrition.
He was at the end of his
career and telling me all
that in the beginning really
helped me kind of at least focus my mind
and be ready to listen to my body and
stay prepared the whole time.
And I think he had a big influence on how
I take care of my body hot prepared in
the summer because he was
relentless in his training.
And I think that was the
basis for, you know, having a,
a pretty good career for me,
for me. Um, as a kid, I think, um,
my mom was my biggest inspiration and she
shared a lot of things with me being a
single parent, raising
three girls. She would,
and then just being so tall, like I
was, I've been taught all my life.
My second grade teacher called
home, it was like, they,
you realize they says taller than
me and the rest of the chosen.
And my mom's like, yeah, well what's
the problem? You know, so, you know,
my mom was like, I'm six to her dad's
six, four. And she said, oh, okay,
we'll excuse the call. So being
this tall all my life, um,
having my mom be so positive about,
you know,
my posture and sitting up
straight and that, you know,
some people grow on the inside and
some people grow on the outside and our
family's been blessed enough to do both.
So don't be ashamed of being tall and
you have to stand up tall. And you know,
there was a lot of that when you're tall
and people ask you every single day,
do you play basketball? And
you're like, no. Like, why do you,
I don't understand the association
with my height and, and basketball.
So for me through just
through grade school,
it was always this barrage of questions
and people talking about my height and
it was really annoying.
When you're a kid you don't really
get the whole comments and stuff.
So my mom was always constantly dropping
in these seats of building me up and
making me feel confident and
comfortable in my own skin.
And I think that the biggest takeaways
that she would tell us was small things.
Like you can't receive
anything with a closed fist.
So always have an open hand and
helping other people, you know,
we're all God's children.
Just, just really a,
a voice of love and positive positivity
that eventually my sister and I were
always like, we're our mother's daughter.
Because all we do is if somebody says,
oh my God, this headache
is killing me. No,
don't say that because
it's not killing you.
You just have a headache this moment,
but you're going to be better. And then,
you know, everything is like
this whole positive affirmation,
but I love it. And the other thing
she would tell us was the seven P's.
The seven p's are proper prior preparation
prevents Piss, poor performance.
So the seven p's with simply
whatever you want to do,
whatever you want to get out of life,
you got to do it. You got to work hard,
but you're going to get out of it.
Whatever effort you put into it.
So if you're going to do it or did
your mom say, do it right there.
Don't do it at all because you're going
to go back and do it anyway in our house.
So it was all of these positive
affirmations that my mom kept getting,
my sisters and I that I felt helped mold
me into being able to accept. I didn't,
God knows, I didn't know I was
going to get to six five mm.
Like this is ridiculous.
I'm like, you know, stop.
What are we doing here?
You know, cause six
like six foot in the sixth
grade. I know, I know, right?
Sixth Grade I was six foot,
they got,
my teacher was six two and there's other
ones are boys, Samuel, he was six foot.
So I'm like perfect. And the tallest
people got to be the line leaders.
I was so excited cause it's
usually the tallest or in the back.
You guys don't feel me, but listen,
this is like a struggle here,
right?
His people [inaudible] exactly.
You're always the line leader.
Right. Who made up that rule.
So anyways,
so all of that was just,
I feel like my mom being so positive
and knowing ahead having to fruition
because her growing up in the
60s being tall, it was just like,
what are you doing?
Like who told you you could grow?
We're going to have to get shoot shoe
boxes for you. She goes, you know,
it was a negative thing and parents and
people made negative comments about tall
women.
So I'm thankful that my mom gave me all
of that positive affirmations and for
all the tall women in the room feel good,
represent,
keep your head up high.
We are just queens amongst the people.
All got tall people problems
was the other one will
come from my mother's.
Well she really, uh, she
really wasn't the vocal.
She led by just showing
a three jobs to care.
Three kids are all on her own,
and I just, her just hustle
and grind every day. And she just, and
she smiled doing it, you know? So, uh,
my mother had been working for Boeing
for like 30 years, and you know, she's,
she been a janitor for 30 years and
she's never complained a day in her life.
And she just goes.
So I just,
I think that's where I get my hunger and
drive from miss from higher for sure.
Thank you.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Chris Webber, Lisa Leslie,
Nate Robinson.